well let's get right to it then shall we
don't take this the wrong way gerard but
you play crazy really well
i'm going to take that the right way i'm
just going to take it
all right thank you yeah it's fun to
you know i guess we all have our dark
sides and it's it's fun to
to um tap into that i don't get to play
the villain
very often and and you it when you do
it's it's interesting to get in there
but give them different colors you know
and yeah be so intimidating and ruthless
and brutal but then just surprise you
with elements of
other you know
whatev whatever that may be that i don't
want to give away too much but yeah it's
fun
i love that alexis would you agree you
have a front row seat to watching this
evolution
he plays crazy pretty great i know he's
real creepy and crazy um in this film
and in this film she want to say in real
life yeah let me
um it it worked very well for
me playing valerie and then also being
opposite frank and
the
it's it's almost like
being the mom with the two siblings just
going back and forth across them like
can y'all just be quiet
now somebody gonna tell the truth over
here
who spilled the wine on the couch
oh i love that i love it both in trouble
for sure gerard you also play you know
romantic characters very well we love
you in that role do you love one more
than the other
or is it just wherever you are at the
time this is wherever i am at the time
you know and and it's nice to change it
up and and kind of
use other creative muscles you know i i
i love the romantic
that you know i love comedies i really
love dark comedies yeah action and then
i even loved small dramas and
shakespeare
all of it you know but um but this one
was just really fun to get my my teeth
into because all the characters are so
fascinating and weird and
dangerous but then and sometimes
surprisingly sweet that you literally
look at every one of them going i kind
of want to play him i'd like to try that
i even want to play i don't even want to
play valerie young because
which is a good sign for a movie i guess
no for sure alexis how much fun did you
have you know playing in this
action-packed movie i had so much fun i
i love doing action and
running and gunning and the and picking
up new skills and the fact that i would
be able to work with such
like
well-known
veterans in this
industry and in this genre like they
taught me a lot and but they were also
like they treated me as a peer and they
didn't send me which was really cool
didn't want you send me what's that mean
you've never heard the films it's like
it's like when when someone older talks
to someone younger and then they like
sun you like like you're their son oh i
see
okay so so far i've gotten better and
older
we're about to go to war
i'm young
yeah we're about the same age but you're
good you're getting it jerome a lot of
your movies turn into huge series like
series of movies are you going to make
more cop shops
um
how could you say no to that
yeah we're gonna make another seven
perfect
all right that's good
um the last time we saw you gerard was
at the toronto international film
festival i think it was for artists for
peace and justice are you going to be
making it back this year for the
festival and for that event
um i don't
think so because i'm going i think i'm
going to be in saudi arabia then making
a making another movie
um
[Music]
which i'm very excited about but i love
coming to toronto as you probably know i
have a major history with toronto you
know i spent a lot of
time there and my my father lived there
and it's one of my favorite places to be
but and i also love the toronto film
festival it's fantastic
but i don't think i'm going to make it
this year
okay well you'll be missed and alexis we
need to get you here also for the film
festival one year
uh would be a great time okay thanks so
much i just got the wrap be well
and um
that's the end of that story okay
you